ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
l'idea del video di oggi mi è
venuta perché stavo ripensando tutte
quelle cose che prima di compiere 18
anni
immaginavo sarebbero successe una volta
compiuti i 18 anni quindi oggi ho voluto
proporvi 18 anni aspettativa vs realtà se
non l' avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale e cliccate sulla campanella vicino
al tasso d'iscrizione per ricevere una
notifica tutte le volte che pubblicherò
un nuovo video iniziamo subito per i
miei 18 anni affitterò un castello
enorme e faró un party che Gossip Girl levate proprio sarà la festa dell'anno non
vedo l'ora
amo ma tra una settimana é il tuo
compleanno i tuoi 18 anni amo lascia stare
hai già organizzato non ho organizzato nulla
perché i miei genitori non vogliono
farmi fare la festa nel castello perché
dicono che costa troppo non vogliono
farmi fare la festa in discoteca perché
hanno paura che ti devo dire andremo al
pub e ci berremmo due birre
l'importante è stare insieme no appena
compirò 18 anni cambierà tutto i miei la
smetteranno di trattarmi come una
ragazzina in primis e poi potrò fare quello
che voglio
finalmente farò parte del mondo degli
adulti non me ne frega niente io a quella
festa ci vado perché ho 18 anni e faccio
quello che voglio ok finché vivai sotto
questo tetto fai quello che ti dico hai
capito
quando compirò 18 anni uscirò tutte le
sere da una festa all'altra questa casa
sarà un albergo amo l'ho già detto anche
a chiara io stasera esco ma vi avviso già
non posso fare tardi quindi mi
raccomando non insistete come lo sai benissimo
che il sabato mattina lavoro devo pure capire il bar ti pare e non posso neanche bere mica arrivo lí ubriaca
ma figurati
e poi quando compirò 18 anni ovviamente
prendere la patente e una volta presa la
patente mi comprerò un macchinone e
porterò in giro tutti i miei amici amo io
sono pronta ci sono ma dai ma passami a
prendere non fare la stronza lo so che devo
prenderla anche io sta benedetta patente
ma non ho avuto tempo lo sai si giuro che
domani vado a iscrivermi promesso
stavolta lo faccia davvero
e poi troverò un bel lavoro e potrò
togliermi tutti sfizi che voglio
viaggi esotici borse firmate scarpe
costose no vabbè questa borsa è pazzesca
la voglio dai mi faccio questo regalo
vediamo quanta costa ma siamo pazzi
questi solidi li guadagno in un mese di lavoro no non posso devo metterli da parte
ma non li metto mai da parte non mi comprerò mai niente potró finalmente dire addio a
tutte quelle paranoie da ragazzina eh sì
perché a diciott'anni diventi più sicura
di te stessa del tuo potenziale della
tua bellezza attiri molti più uomini e
finalmente dirò addio a tutte le ore
passate a guardare il cellulare
aspettando il messaggio del ragazzo che
mi piace
adesso mi scrive
1 2 3 perché non mi scrivi maledetto cosa
ti ho fatto dl male è uscito con me così
per passare il tempo non te ne frega
niente vero
mia mamma e poi la smetterò di sognare eh sì perché a 18 anni i sogni sono molto
più realizzabili nel giro di due tre
anni diventerò milionaria come minimo
alla fine sono ancora giovane posso
aspettare a diventare milionaria
magari a 40 anni avrò la mia azienda e farò l'imprenditrice e diventerò milionaria
oppure a 60 siamo purtroppo
arrivati alla fine del video spero che
vi sia piaciuto e che vi siate in
qualche modo ritrovati
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
se avete già compiuto 18 anni o non
gli avete ancora compiuti e seguitemi su
tutti gli altri social facebook instagram
e tiktok
io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video